bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
el invitado de hoy es petro poroshenko
fue el presidente de ucrania entre 2014
y 2019 nos acompaña desde quiere muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros es un
placer gracias
señor poroshenko los soldados ucranianos
están siendo evacuados de la planta así
era un libradas hostal en los están
evacuando hacia zona bajo control
incluso está preocupado por ellos
definitivamente
primero que todos los soldados de mario
pues son ahora un símbolo de la valentía
son un símbolo del heroísmo no sólo para
lucrarme sino para todo el mundo libre
puede imaginarse 83 días sin comida sin
municiones sin agua
ellos siguen luchando
cansados contra 22.000 tropas rusas para
impedir que desarrollen sus operaciones
en otras direcciones
[Música]
y ante esta situación primero quiero
apreciar los esfuerzos del secretario
general de naciones unidas
antonio gutiérrez
el presidente de la ce icr peter mauer y
del presidente turco ersan y muchos
otros que hacen esfuerzos enormes por
evacuar que los soldados ucranianos
pero por favor les pido que no confíen
en putin
putin encarceló a héroes ucranianos en
la lista
y ahora nosotros el mundo entero
queremos saber cuándo estará el libre de
los soldados ucranianos
y cuando regresaran a ucrania
deberíamos concentrar nuestros esfuerzos
en hacer presión
es importante conocer las condiciones de
evacuación de los soldados ucranianos de
asof tal
y definitivamente necesitamos verificar
las condiciones bajo las cuales recursos
tienen que ser los ucranianos
sí porque ya ha habido llamados a rusia
en el luma de moscú para que esos
soldados sean juzgados
confía en que las autoridades ucranianas
tengan buenas garantías
y qué valor tienen esa garantía viniendo
de parte de vladimir putin
yo no tengo esa información y es mejor
preguntárselo a los negociadores
ucranianos involucrados en el proceso no
quiero hacer comentarios ahora
y debilitar la posición de ucrania eso
no lo permitimos
pero he tenido la experiencia de cinco
años de negociación con putin
desde el 2014 hasta 2019 y de nuevo mi
recomendación es que nunca te fíes putin
putin me prometió liberar a nadie hace
acción con álex in soft y a otros quiero
recordarles que sacamos de la cárcel
cruz a más de 3.000 civiles y soldados
ucranianos y sé lo que significa eso
ante esta situación el mundo debería
estar unido y recordar que los
resultados ucranianos que están en as
hortas el mariupol luchan por nuestra
libertad
luchan por la democracia luchan por
mandar a rusia de regreso a la frontera
internacional reconocida de la
federación rusa
y con esta situación usted tiene toda la
razón
la discusión que hubo ayer en la duma
rusa en el parlamento ruso diciendo que
torturarían a los héroes ucranianos
esa es exactamente la manera de pensar
de putin
de los parlamentarios rusos locos y
maníacos que iniciaron ayer esta fe
[Música]
quiero regresar a la situación general
en el terreno
rusia se ha retirado de quiere donde
está usted y también dejar ir
pero parece que están haciendo progresos
en el donbass
donde parecen estar a punto de tener el
control
nos estamos dirigiendo a una partición
de ucrania con rusia controlando por
completo más
primero que todo no es una retirada de
los rusos es el trabajo de las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas y estoy muy orgulloso
de haber creado como presidente las
fuerzas armadas italianas en el año 2014
porque esta es una de las fuerzas
armadas más fuertes de europa del
continente
y estamos pagando un precio muy alto por
sacar a los rusos del territorio
alrededor de kiev
de ser mi jefe de sume de poltava
y ahora estamos luchando por sacarlos
del jardín
y esto es una muestra de que hoy llevan
12 semanas y casi 3 meses
y putin había prometido en vadhir
ucrania en tres días
quiero recordarles que fueron las
fuerzas armadas bajo mi mando
como comandante supremo de las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas las que liberaron dos
tercios del tomás ocupado por las tropas
rusas en el año 2014
esa es la verdad
tenemos experiencia
[Música]
cuando están haciendo contraataques
operaciones ofensivas
eso está pasando cerca de rubí sant
antoni
cerca de severodonezk
capturaron copas las y entendemos lo
difícil que es esta lucha
pero solo quiero recordarles que más de
28.000 soldados rusos se quedarán por
siempre aquí
como un pago por la idea loca y maníaca
y mayoritaria que tuvo el presidente
ruso
más de 4500 tantes rusos y vehículos
blindados para transporte de tropas
rusas
más de 350 miles de combate y
helicópteros rusos
y porque ahora es posible no sólo
detener sino contraatacar en dirección
del jardín
gracias a su ayuda
gracias a sus armas pesadas que hemos
empezado a recibir
howitt ser
los 37 los misiles antiaéreos
antitanque y sólo quiero recordarles que
la condición que podría cambiar la
situación
son sólo 500 tanques o 1000 vehículos de
combate a nivel de combate o 300 misiles
entre ellos
esto cambiaría por completo todo el
futuro de europa cambiaría por completo
toda la sociedad global
contamos con su ayuda estamos esperando
su ayuda de definitivamente espero que
la convención telefónica de ayer entre
selenski lima grand haya activado esta
cooperación porque lo que necesitamos
ahora para la seguridad global son tres
cosas armas armas y armas
armas pesadas y antiaéreas embargo y
sanciones y de esputo izar la rusia de
putin nada más
hay reportes de que su sucesor
provinciales que recientemente le dijo a
un medio italiano
que no estaba contento de que el
presidente francés dijera que debían
hacerse concesiones diplomáticas a bush
está de acuerdo con él en que europa ni
siquiera debería estar hablando con
putin en este punto
mire tengo una experiencia muy positiva
de la cooperación con los dos
presidentes franceses con los que
trabajé
françois blanco y enmanuel macrón y solo
quiero recordarle que el primer gesto de
apoyo fue cancelar el contrato sobre la
ministra el francés que le habían
prometido a rusia
puede imaginarse que usted tuviera ahora
ese portahelicópteros mistral eso
significaría que sin duda habrían podido
de la cabeza
y tendríamos una situación mucho más
difícil
además el presidente marrón es un gran
amigo de ucrania
es un político con experiencia y ahora
lo que necesitamos es entender mejor la
situación
primero y este es un mensaje para todos
los líderes de la gente
no habrá compromisos en la integridad
territorial
es lo mismo que proponer la francia que
por esta unidad entre provença y còrsega
putin no es posible y segundo
no hay que aplacar al agresor porque
ucrania está pagando ahora el precio el
ejército ruso no solo está luchando
contra los soldados ucranianos
viola antoni durán hace una masacre
contra las mujeres contra los niños
contra las personas mayores
y nunca olvidaremos eso y nunca los
perdonaré mos
hacemos lo posible para que nuestro país
regrese a la familia europea
y hacemos lo posible por unirnos a la
otan y por mantener a europa segura
porque no hay ninguna otra nación en el
mundo que quiera la paz en más que
nosotros
y estamos dispuestos a alcanzarla a
través de negociaciones diplomáticas
a través de métodos políticos
diplomáticos y también con las fuerzas
armadas
pero necesitamos separar esta
negociación diplomática y eso está
basado en mi experiencia de negociación
con putin
primero debe haber un alto el fuego
inmediato y sin condiciones una retirada
de las tropas rusas y la resolución de
todos los problemas humanitarios
realicen de
soltar a los rehenes y todo lo demás
cerca
y segundos son las condiciones para la
seguridad
si rusia necesita cualquier tipo de
garantía nosotros estaríamos dispuestos
a hacer todo lo posible para
garantizarlo
y quiero repetir mi invitación para mi
amigo y gran amigo de ucrania y manuel
macrón presidente de la república
francesa de que visite quiere esto es
extremadamente importante pasar de la
imaginación a verlo con los propios ojos
el desastre en mucha angosto melzer y
poro dianca en andrés cap en borssele el
ser ni cif o en kiev porque yo he estado
todos los 83 días aquí en kiev y cada
día y cada noche y misiles de crucero
que matan docenas de civiles sabemos lo
que significa mantenemos la unidad y
mantenemos la solidaridad con francia y
con el múltiple
petro poroshenko muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros desde quieren la
entrevista de france 24 y gracias a
ustedes por acompañarnos
[Música]